Izzy's from Nigeria right he's Nigerian
so you gotta remember Izzy was born in
Africa moved to New Zealand when he's a
young kid and got bullied because he
didn't look like the other kids in New
Zealand so he grew up with that fire in
his belly not fitting in getting made
fun of because he didn't look like a New
Zealander that made fun of him from
being from Africa that's what makes Izzy
who he is and so you're you're kind of
poking that you're saying ah you're not
really an African
man you're up when you give Izzy
a reason to train you give him a reason
to focus and a reason to get up in the
morning and run those miles and put in
the work that it takes to be at his
level when you give him not only a
reason but you give him the reason
you're bringing in a cultural aspect to
it and you're touching nerves in Izzy
that haven't been touched before and you
you woke up the the sleeping giant it
just so happens that that sleeping giant
is the best in the world